Lois Lane say hello to Clark
any more at home like you
[Music]
uh not really no
how'd you like your first day on the job
[Music]
easy Miss I've got you
oh I'd say you can swell swell
to commit the crime in the century a man
will just naturally want to face the
challenge of the century
the opportunity of destroying everything
that he represents oh just take the
gentleman's cape
I don't think he wants me to Mr Luther
is that how a warped brain like yours
gets its kicks by planning the death of
innocent people no
I'm causing the death of innocent people
bye-bye in California
you were great in your day Superman
but it just has to reason when it came
time to cash in your chips
maniac
your Banker
the problem with Men of Steel there's
never one around when you want one
I'm sorry about that Lois
but I've been kind of busy for a while
[Music]